this was almost 20 years ago US and
British forces invaded Afghanistan
following the September 11 attacks on
the United States the goal to stop this
land from ever again being used as a
launch pad by al-qaeda for terrorism the
Taliban government that gave the group a
safe haven was forced out but it fought
back now the u.s. is preparing to make
peace with its enemy the deal with the
Taliban affects Britain - its troops
have fought and died here I asked a
former top commander if the sacrifice
had been worthwhile if this truce works
and the Taliban have seen the light of
the day and can be integrated in a
constructive way and there's no hint of
any more terrorists operations being
mounted from within Afghanistan then I
for one will say that this was a
necessary war which we fought well and
and the result has been a draw if not
the conventional victory we might have
hoped back in 2006 how does it feel to
be at this point of a peace deal between
the United States and the Taliban my
feeling is that it's we don't certainly
have to be ashamed from this if it will
work there's a lot of risk in this
though and we must be prepared to do
again with the Americans on our allies
what might be required for another few
years to remind the Taliban that we will
there's a line beyond which we won't go
the deal hinges around a gradual
withdrawal of US British and other NATO
forces in return
the Taliban agrees to a ceasefire and
direct talks with these people the
Afghan government it's a gamble that
Donald Trump promised his voters he'd
end what he's called endless wars in an
election year what better time to bring
thousands of US troops home not
everyone's convinced Victoria lost her
husband Lance Corporal James Bateman
when British forces surged
into southern Afghanistan in 2006 mixed
feelings really I think anything that
can bring pace to a region that's been
so unstable would be amazing I said
about however I think personally it's
doing a deal with the devil it's a
feeling shared by many here in
Afghanistan
most people have known nothing but war
few dare to believe the deal will really
bring peace
Deborah Haines Sky News